on the,
first twenty-four.
safe
they have also from the publication of corrective
heard.
it is the recherche
From corrective
about atorial meeting in Potsdam,
which is staged as a dramatic stage play
and to analyze the text.
briefly,
the linguistic and pictorial design of the corrective
Text seems rather
literary and as
journalistic.
Pictures and floor plans of the meeting do not provide
substantial evidence and
remind of wanted photos.
corrective shafts
Do not support the serious allegations of a
Conspiracy to expel millions
From Germany.
the research
appears subjective and speculative,
Whereby
the corrective article often refers to itself.
therefore,
valid sources are lacking
such as invitations or recordings
and some participants
were simply not asked for position names either.
focusing on Martin Selner
and connections to dark chapters of the
German history
are clear to be viewed critically.
the accusation of remigration 1
Core theme is not new
and is also discussed by many parties.
the presentation of the script
on stage soon reinforces the impression
of a.
ive
remains evidence of his serious allegations
Allegations guilty,
what yes questions about credibility and uh,
"journal integrity.
read the whole analysis of the text now
on Club of Clear Words.
en.
i'm glad they come across this.